the shoppers inside this montreal
grocery store will soon look very
different masks will no longer be
mandatory in public indoor spaces in
quebec it will be the last province to
drop the mandate
it's fun to know that finally we're
gonna turn the page
like other jurisdictions quebec will
still require masks in certain settings
like public transit and hospitals prince
edward island removes its mandate friday
it's the only other province still
masking ontario and alberta lifted
requirements in march still many in
montreal feel it's just too soon i'm
still going to keep it for for quite
quite a while
if the convince is a risk
are going to keep it quebec says with
cases hospitalizations and deaths
trending downward the timing is backed
up by data but like in ontario quebec
voters head to the polls soon
immunologist dr andre veyet thinks that
is a major motivator he would have
waited longer you know they do surveys
and they see how the mood of the
population is going and i'm sure this
kind of thing is not the only factor but
it's one of the factors montreal public
health has released new research about
outbreaks in workplaces finding during
the first three pandemic waves that
people who work in food processing
warehousing and manufacturing were the
hardest hit though hard lessons have
been learned and vaccination is more
widespread than ever workers in those
sectors remain vulnerable it's not
because the masks are not mandatory that
it's mandatory not to wear them and the
more we don't wear masks many
immunocompromised people are feeling
anxious and left behind it's like
they're taking away from drivers your
airbag and your seatbelt and so if i'm
still wearing a mask it's not enough
people are of course free to continue
wearing masks with officials reminding
quebecers to respect the choices of
their neighbors dan specter global news
montreal